[Music]
but we want to bring rob on because he
was texting me pretty furiously about
how some of our predictions that we were
kind of nervous about after i think was
last week we did what we wanted
battlefront two were like [ __ ] we didn't
even talk about like the new order or
whatnot and everything like that would
make sense because that's the last movie
that came out and we talked about the
Clone Wars really what were we thinking
but then robtex means like dude it's all
three arrows I'm like oh now we look
kind of smart ah but I want to bring you
on we're gonna have John Luke and back
kind of scrub through the teaser trailer
from what you say you know like there's
a decent amount of things you looked at
you know went crazy like scientists
looking at there's a little more that
you might have missed yeah that day
every second quick trailer so here it is
well kind of watch it once yeah um you
know again just to preface all this like
this is still going to be a lot of
speculation I mean I'd you know what is
confirmed right based on this is that
you are playing as I would believe a
female imperial officer of some sort but
after Return of the Jedi so post deaths
are to the fall of the Empire which i
think is it's kind of surprising but it
all ultimately makes so much sense as
far as okay they want to tell a story
that hasn't been told this all ideally
and that has not really been told that
whole gap and there was the book
aftermath and all that stuff this is
still untouched and also they probably
have a lot more freedom as Lucasfilm I'm
sure everyone knows it's like constantly
gripping right like they are very
uptight with anything it's you know it's
their baby um so it's a great timepiece
I mean that's super interesting yeah it
does it seems kind of like what it's
doing what rogue one did at the sense
that rogue one kind of it didn't really
bridge the gap between Revenge of the
Sith and a new hope but it's still
filled in some info we didn't that we
had only heard alluded to in a new hope
what is this yes what are you doing the
dead Yoda and kylo Ren in the same
trailer okay no so that's that's where
if there's one thing that we mentioned
last week our predictions that seems to
be the case is that we are gonna get the
hero systems when you say timepiece
that's what I'm like oh wow
understand like that part you're
describing but then it just all kind of
gets flushed down the toilet when they
show like everyone's here yes I am yeah
well I want the Harlem Globetrotters I
am on board with you uh Joe Darth Maul I
got Yoda you got rank kylo Ren to me to
me what this infers again the hero
systems strictly for multiplayer I would
be very surprised if they are going all
over the place in the single-player
campaign I think yeah I think the
single-player campaign this time around
which you know like if you don't know
battlefront 2 does have a dedicated
single-player campaign with a story and
everything I would be surprised yeah i
mean like they would keep i'm assuming
they'll keep the multiplayer that kind
of Star Wars toy box aspect the star
wars fantasy like battlefront 2 yeah and
then you have this focused single-player
story which will fill in the gaps
between return of the jedi and force
away force awakens yes I don't know how
far because I think they're also playing
it safe where it's still like familiar
original trilogy right like I mean
they're still star straw yrs they're
still going to be tie fighters granted
there were Thai fighters mean obviously
force awakens but I'm curious to see how
far they go because I mean what's that
gap it's like over 20 years I believe it
at least yeah so I I wouldn't expect to
see any major I mean you might see smoke
maybe that's I mean that's when he picks
up everything right so maybe that's and
you know I could almost see like the
character you play as defecting in the
end almost like a thin kind of roll it
seems like they're kind of taking pics
so if we have the trailer and kind of
start combing through cuz I have ya got
a couple cool no John Luke throw that up
and robbed can kind of narrate it and
yeah so you're yeah you're inferring
because there's a voice right she sees i
believe the line remember line if you
pause it right here go back is that hurt
the protagonist i would imagine that's a
close-up I mean someone is talking right
now I didn't she benches along the lines
of like dampers dead we need to get
revenge right so she's still with the
Empire members on indoors yeah yeah so
this is n door now these are not your
typical stormtroopers right these are
kind of like it's like almost like
they're pulling from rogue one right
with those the death squad troopers
these look like more like pilots to me
when I that's what I'm gathering to so
this is where it's all speculation
however
again I was looking at all reddit stuff
if you watch rebels the show that droid
they're hovering around right there
obviously on the left is an ID nine
seeker droid BAM wow I'm Loretta
imperial probe droid from far away yeah
but they're a little cooler Mike
obviously these in the show I have not
seen the show unfortunately but they uh
they crawl they fly they mimic other
droids there's they have electric probes
there they're kind of like a cool
sidekick okay so i can see that playing
a nice role as you are which now is
speculation even further a is that you
play so this is a character that that's
from the rebels she is a Jedi hunter
like a Sith Inquisitor imperial
Inquisitor um is that the role you're
playing cuz you're not you're definitely
not you know if you were to compare it
to Finn you're not a janitor right yeah
you're higher up you're flying around in
that slick looking [ __ ] that reminds me
of Darth Maul's uh infiltrator uh you're
higher up is what I'm I'm under the
impression of me she she specifically
she sounds kind of like lemon full about
she's like I remember the last orders I
had or I can't remember the exact line
but she's talking about that and she's
called the unlike the untold soldier
story right so very likely was weird
because you know like force awakens a
big thing with fins that they're kind of
implying he's not just this normal
person cuz I'm wondering why I like the
Imperial brainwashing whatever they do
wouldn't work on her specifically like
why would she have a change of heart oh
that's a good point um well maybe the
whole thing was Finn is everybody theory
is oh he's force-sensitive he really is
and then that's why he was like turn
around that's why phasma did the whole
like go back to conditioning or whatever
well orissa wakens in in this era of the
three eras how strong tutors are picked
or we is you can volunteer as possible
[ __ ] that she volunteered just as the
rebelled the fight with a rebellion got
worse they they needed volunteers sure i
mean and i would i would say that you
know as this new first order is being a
stab
list maybe that's why she defects again
who knows if she does or not but yeah
look at that really helm in the back
yeah right Nick these this seems like a
pretty unique squad I think what are
they implying that that's the helmet she
would be wearing she had one on because
that's a red helm in the back I don't
know reading too far no but that's a
cool hell no it looks like a black storm
trooper with like a read on the side I'm
gonna read touch and you know what
that's like that reminds me of first
order right that's what the first order
real so Blaine leave amped on just like
or there's readily nochi stuff she has
read on her right shoulder too yeah yeah
yeah we keep moving along there's not a
whole lot yeah so this is this reminds
me a lot sorry this is darth maul's
cruiser the infiltrator blue is called
sis infiltrator and it looked it just
remind me a lot of the ship you see this
is small i would say like a smaller form
so you keep playing or now start the
trailer really i think it kicks off with
that perfect everyone a little boy yeah
like the first shot had a better take of
it I know John Luke is frantically
scrubbing and again more about you know
this trailer was 30 seconds it felt
quick and we have been told that we're
expecting something really big right a
really big reveal so we can write like
this is just a TV ad you know I mean it
felt very spoon-fed with all these this
text like so here's this classic
dogfight so that's Starkiller base so
you can you can definitely count on may
be replaying that battle from force
awakens in multiplayer or like I mean
ideally in my what the hell yeah
exclusive gameplay haha no when sky is
not in oh so that's cool so if you
rewind a little more I'm with that uh
what I'm stoked on is that if you know
again the force awakens was really neat
with their um you know it reminds you a
lot of like n like World War to like not
see red flags like yeah yeah plainly
evil and that's what it was so neat
about force awakens so you're seeing a
lot of here which is really neat right
like the tree and the flag in the
background I think that is a cool visual
style and palette that works well we've
seen it in battlefield one you know I
mean look like a lot of orange and like
against this really bland dark d
saturated ground it's cool if you keep
going
this is a pretty obvious nod to the
first trailer right or when the
resistance is coming into exactly and
that is the wrote that down what's the
plan because I don't remember tikona I
didn't write down when they go see Maz
to oh yeah what is that took the temple
guides it's lose cantina planet yes yeah
uh so you can imagine some stuff there
and of course what everyone's
remembering is all right time which to
me says we're going back to Hoth and I
don't give up f about Hoff man I think
that is just the most tired level in in
all star wars games I just don't care
even walkers I don't know I like and
that's where i think it's it's not a
bummer but i think it's like again smart
i mean everyone knows of the Imperial
walkers and stuff like it's just it's
interesting it's in it's a cooler story
at new locations yeah it's kind of the
same stuff and I'm hoping for for rebel
vehicles to be honest if it is a TV spot
than it would make sense that they would
include more like the most recognizable
imagery I think um and it I mean yeah
yeah no I yeah it's good point i mean
let's hope that's know any what's funny
think two is like nothing but
battlefield one like the horse it's like
their high horses it's like so someone
was just like dude let's do Don talents
I don't know it's like funny thing and
obviously here's mall and Yoda cuz you
know remember that yeah this is
instantly turns me on I do dad bothers
me so much it just does not waited to
value these characters but I mean the
original not that this makes it okay but
the original battlefront one and two had
like the its kind of battles in the
multiplayer and they did it well i think
is it was more about you know just this
star wars fans fantasy in the
multiplayer sure which I'm fine with
that here if they do use like that more
gritty boots on the ground soldier's
story that seems like I mean baseness
teaser they're gonna do and I have you
already kind of have the fantasy thing
and the last game and the one from years
ago right so that's I'm saying I'm
hoping I'm getting more grounded thing
in the single-player campaign so if
we're just going to do this in
multiplayer than that's I guess that's
fine if they can do
well I'm hoping like I don't know we
keep scrubbing through I guess Rob but
yeah I just know again we talked about
the hero system I mean there's no I
there's a part of me that wants to see
how they do like kylo Ren right you see
him in the end yeah if you remember from
the movies like he did stop a bullet
from uh like full speed heading towards
well I'll that even happen to forget who
shot that it was a podium road yeah I
mean he just stopped a bullet like
that'd be a cool move but again I don't
care should play as any of these heroes
yep yeah uh so that is just like a
straight-up shot from force awakens it
looks like not in like actual shop it
very reminiscent it is interesting to me
that they are ya including the clone war
era prequel era which we actually said
we hoped for because I was the one
redeeming quality for me for the
prequels was the the actual you know the
battles the clone wars and selves
they're covering I think Kelly you and
Rob you both said the same thing you
were hoping yeah I really wanted to do
like actual battles like on a larger
scale I'm I'm less drawn towards the
individual like hero stuff than I am
towards the grander scale of it yeah is
this this is toward the end of the
trailer right yeah yeah this is it okay
and then here uh obviously like I mean
there's that like row you know it's
funny how there's is like feels like
they're nitpicking different aspects you
know I just keep think of gin or so like
the at one shot to never end up using in
the movie but you know just that
Imperial pilot look it's cool and then
also in the background someone point out
like separatist ships I can't really
psych us on the left there that's a
separatist ship oh uh federacy says yeah
yeah i'm i'm wondering if they're gonna
focus too much on rope one if they
already did all that dlc with the first
game oh well if you see the bottom there
you're definitely gonna get some last
Jedi yeah stuff so what old Luke yeah oh
wait what you can oh my god i I'm
speculating okay an old old yeah
Skywalker the cane yeah alright well
anything else to add are you okay
actually I want to ask you guys are you
more excited for the game now after
seeing this yeah I'm
I'm much more excited about this game uh
namely the single player i think that's
cool i'm really hoping they do some need
with that yeah like tell a really
interesting story and again like that's
hard to do in in a universe like with
the original trilogy or any of these
because it's been told like how do you
tie in a character with you know ab +
favorites like I hope they don't do that
as much obviously but there's it's like
it just feels like a clean plate and
that's really nice Kelly you'll be
seeing this soon couple days three days
or so yeah i'm i'm really excited I'm uh
I'm gonna be that person and say I'm
always more excited for like more female
heroes in Star Wars just cuz that was I
was really no star wars as a kid that
was the one thing that was always
missing for me so I the kid in me it
gets just really excited about having
another female hero too um whose story
we get to tell and I am also one of
those people who liked rogue one I
really enjoyed rogue one so I'm excited
about the prospect of doing sort of like
you were saying a more like soldier war
focused sort of thing with her so I'm
very intrigued by her you don't seem too
excited I mean I'm with you guys right I
like the idea that's gonna have single
player there's there's like well how do
we know it's gonna be any good how do I
know yeah like I can't get excited for
anything yet because this sure this is
literally just like people you love
ships that look awesome you love Star
Wars right okay I don't think you do
love Star Wars Pete I like Star Wars
when it's not just exploited for the
just yeah just just a cell right I am
one person I hope they pull more from
battlefield one than they do from
battlefront with this like being dice oh
yeah they take cues from battlefield
ones gameplay hey I don't want I don't
mean story-wise like I don't want
they're like storm troopers running into
the trenches on their dune or something
that's how many men just a couple of war
shooter fans yeah yeah I mean tell that
story and then and that's where I'm a
little concerned as well in that uh of
what like action not gameplay obviously
that we've seen it still looks exactly
like Battlefront yeah and like it
again one of my frustrations with out
front was just the lack of diversity
it's just like Imperial Walker's rebels
getting stomped on but I am really
overseeing that and that is littered
with it and it looked a lot like battle
friend it looks good but it looked a lot
like that last game so i just re again
what i really want to see some new stuff
but that's what's neat about this idea
is that at least for the single player
like yeah it seems a little more
open-ended
[Music]